es waren fünf Züge danach wollte er
immer mehr mehr Crystal Meth mehr
Metamphetamin mehr von der Droge dient
anfangs so stark machte
[Musik]
wenn ich darüber spreche dann ekel ich
mich selbst vor mir das ist eine Welt
die ganz anders ist als dein
wir nennen den Mann vor wenigen Jahren
noch war er Personenschützer in Bagdad
jetzt macht er sein Geld mit
Crew sagen wir ich habe 50 Gramm auf der
Straße verkaufe ich aber nur 30 der Rest
ist für mich die Hälfte von jedem Gramm
stecke ich mehr
schau ich habe da so eine spezielle
Technik ich roll das so da ist nur ein
halbes Gramm drin aber auf der Straße
sieht es aus wie ein ganzes natürlich
beschweren sich meine Kunden später aber
das scheiß ich drauf so ist nun mal das
Geschäft die sind krank die brauchen den
Zug und wenn sie ihn haben ist alles
vergessen
am nächsten Tag kommen die doch eh
zurück weil sie mich brauchen
und seine Kunden werden immer mehr
unterwegs in einem Armenviertel in
Bagdad im Irak wir müssen aus dem Auto
Film um unsere Sicherheit nicht zu
gefährden hier lebt eine Jugend ohne
Perspektive erst der Krieg nun
Wirtschaftskrise und Inflation auf der
Suche dem Alltag zu entfliehen sollen so
schätzen Experten 40% der Bevölkerung
Drogen konsumieren besonders verbreitet
Crystal Meth
die Drogen sind heute gefährlicher als
der Terrorismus und der is den is kann
man sehen und bekämpfen aber die Drogen
sind plötzlich da völlig unsichtbar
Drogen fahren das zeigt uns Videos
Razzien der drogeneinheit des
Innenministeriums
16.800 Festnahmen habe es allein letztes
Jahr gegeben
3,5 Tonnen sein konfisziert worden
im Irak wird jeder Kontakt mit Drogen
streng geahndet
sogar die abhängigen haben hohe
Gefängnisstrafen zu fürchten
doch weil die Gefängnisse voll sind mit
abhängigen wird das Innenministerium nun
gar mit Straffreiheit für all jene die
sich im Krankenhaus behandeln lassen
die Nachfrage ist hoch die Ärzte
beklagen es gebe viel zu wenige Betten
für die ganzen abhängigen und es seien
nicht nur Männer die Hilfe brauchen
wovon bist du abhängig Christel seit
wann fünf Jahre wie hat es angefangen
durch meinen Mann
nimmst du es noch ja erst war es ein
Gramm
ihr Mann wurde vor drei Tagen verhaftet
er ist ein Dealer weil die junge Frauen
nicht wusste wie einen neuen Stoff
kommen entscheidet sie sich zum Entzug
und riskiert damit einiges
es ist wirklich nicht erlaubt in unserer
Gesellschaft dass eine Frau Crystal
nimmt es ist nicht erlaubt aber es ist
sehr verbreitet so wie die Korruption
Christel ist überall
doch das wolle sie nun hinter sich
lassen denn mit dem Crystal kam auch die
Gewalt in ihrer Ehe erzählt Esra
[Musik]
es gab viele viele Male wo mein ganzer
Körper geschwollen war weil er nach zwei
drei Tagen auf Drogen aggressiv wurde in
diesem Moment wollte ich ihn verlassen
aber weil ich abhängig bin konnte ich ja
nicht zu meiner Familie zurück
aber warum nicht
meine Familie würde mich töten wenn sie
das wüssten weil einer Frau darf das
nicht passieren in unserer Kultur ist
das schon für einen Mann schwierig aber
für Frauen
sie würden mich Köpfen
wirklich umbringen ja umbringen
[Musik]
14 Tage dauert die Behandlung danach so
sagt Esra will sie neu anfangen
und unterwegs raus aus ihrer Zeit
Richtung Iran von hier kommt das
Christel
eine Region die von religiösen
schiitischen Milizen kontrolliert wird
nirgends im Land so erzählt man uns sein
mehr crystalle im Umlauf gebe es mehr
abhängige als hier
Mittagspause in der örtlichen
Entzugsklinik 44 Patienten wohnen hier
für zwei bis vier Wochen die meisten
Männer sind zwischen 16 und 30 Jahre alt
ein Großteil von ihnen ist
kristallabhängig ihre Chancen geheilt zu
werden liegen bei 75% sagen die Ärzte
sogar sein Auto habe dieser Mann
verkauft um an Drogen zu kommen erzählt
er uns er war bereit alles aus Spiel zu
setzen
wenn ich druck hatte aber kein Geld dann
habe ich alle beklaut
von seinem Entzug aber weiß die
zukünftige nicht Abhängigkeit bleibt
eines der Tabuthemen im Irak deshalb
gebe es viel zu wenige
Behandlungsmöglichkeiten kaum Chancen
die Verbreitung der Drogen in den Griff
zu bekommen
wenn es mehr Entzugskliniken gäbe dann
wären auch die abhängigkeitsraten nicht
so hoch
weil der Kampf gegen Crystal so kaum zu
gewinnen ist ist der Drogenfahnder Ali
schaja in die Jugendarbeit eingestiegen
die wollen die irakische Jugend um ihr
Leben und ihren Erfolg bringen
die wollen eine Generation sprechen
eine ganze Generation
der hier im Grenzgebiet so einflussreich
ist
dazu komme der alkoholmann den die
irakische Regierung im Frühjahr erlassen
hat
die Drogen verbreiten sich auch deswegen
in diesem großen Ausmaß weil Alkohol
verboten wurde
und die Jungs sehr einfach an die Drogen
rankommen
und Crystal stoppe vor keiner sozialen
Schicht er stellt uns Mustafa vor seit
der Oberschule sei er abhängig gewesen
er kommt aus einer angesehenen Familie
hat Frau und Kinder deshalb will er
nicht erkannt werden
ich habe es immer weiter genommen und
viele Menschen getroffen die es mir
gleich Taten
Regierungsangestellte sogar acht Jahre
war ich auf Drogen
all mein Gehalt ging drauf das Zeug zu
kaufen es war einfach kein Ende in Sicht
die Wahl schien Tod oder Gefängnis
über die sozialen Medien findet Mustafa
zu Ali Shaya
die meisten jungen Männer bleiben
abhängig weil sie Angst haben vor
Bestrafung das ist eine der Ursachen die
Angst vor der Bestrafung
der Drogenfahnder besorgt Mustafa ein
Platz in einem Krankenhaus weit entfernt
von der Heimat so kann die Familie ihr
Gesicht waren und Mustafa kann entziehen
er gehört zu den wenigen die es wirklich
schaffen wegzukommen von der Droge der
Drogenfahnder nimmt uns mit ins örtliche
Gefängnis
es ist völlig überfüllt
wir sehen eine Zelle mit hunderten
Gefangenen auf engstem Raum Film dürfen
wir das nicht
hüssein hat studiert seit zwei Jahren
sitzt er mit 230 anderen Gefangenen in
einer Zelle mit zwei Toiletten und einer
Dusche unschuldig behauptet er
ich bin Taxifahrer
ein Kunde hat mich gebeten ihn in eine
Gegend in Basra zu fahren er traf einen
Freund von dem er Drogen bekam
als er mit einem plastikpäckchen zurück
in mein Auto kam sagte er mir dass
seinen Drogen und bat mich ihn damit in
eine andere Gegend als wir losfahren
wurden wir festgenommen
200 Dollar sollte Hussein für die Fahrt
bekommen sein Urteil fünf Jahre und ein
Monat Haft wegen Drogenhandel
er schätzt das rund 80% der Gefangenen
beschuldigt sein mit Drogen zu handeln
20% der Insassen sein abhängig doch
ausnahmslos alles hier haben mit Drogen
zu tun ein Großteil mit Christa
verhaftet es war nicht mein Zeug es
gehört einem Freund ich habe es nur
zwischengelagert
die Strafe des 52-Jährigen
Familienvaters
lebenslänglich
zurück bei Drogen die larssony warum
fühlt er sich so sicher fürchtet er
nicht die Justiz
[Musik]
die Regierung ist kaputt komplett kaputt
die meisten Drogendealer kommen doch aus
der Regierung es sind hohe Offiziere ich
sage euch die Wahrheit das ist was ich
selber gesehen habe die meisten der
großen Dealer sind hohe Offiziere aus
der nationalen Sicherheit dem
Geheimdienst und der Landespolizei und
wenn die dir sagen mach weiter und
verkaufe dann heißt das du bist sicher
überprüfen können wir nicht was er sagt
fest steht Crystal Meth sind sich
Strafverfolgungsbehörden Dealer Ärzte
und abhängige einig Stürze das Land
immer tiefer in die Krise
[Musik]